E aí
[Música]
E desde pequena eu tenho uma paixão
muito grande pela música com um ano e
meio de idade já cantava várias músicas
da Xuxa com muita felicidade com seis
anos de idade eu entrei para aula de
violino porque eu amava aquele
instrumento e aquela forma suave e doce
de tocar Mas eu também me lembro a
primeira vez que chegar me disseram para
mim que aquilo era bobagem que não fazia
sentido que não era legal resultado eu
parei de fazer violino e para não ter
muita gente conversa desconforto lá em
casa simplesmente a gente conversava e
disse que tinha parado de gostar nesse
momento
crianças Elas costumam ser bem
autênticas quando novas mas ela só
perdendo assistência ao longo da vida
quem de fato não se lembra de uma época
quando criança Que adorava determinado
assunto brincadeira mas acabou sendo
reprimido por isso e deixou de lado
a autenticidade ela é uma palavra que
está muito na moda mas o que de fato a
gente realmente deveria estar pensando é
o com disposto você está para correr
atrás da sua felicidade
eu vou contar a história de duas pessoas
que trilharam o caminho bem semelhante
nessa jornada e eu confesso que eu
demorei muito tempo para entender toda
essa esse processo mas eu vou tentar
resumir essa história toda em alguns
minutos para vocês a primeira pessoa se
chama Tiago para essa pessoa que está na
tela ele também permitiu que eu pudesse
eu compartilhar bem detalhadamente as
principais motivos de segurança e
dificuldades que ele teve nesse caminho
o Thiago ele tem uma família super
estruturada que sempre encheu de carinho
ele adora sair com os amigos gosto de
tocar bateria nas horas vagas trabalha
bastante também adoram videogame Ele
sempre teve relacionamentos duradouros
com suas namoradas e podemos dizer que o
Thiago é vive uma vida conforme o padrão
é só que ele foi desenvolvendo uma crise
de ansiedade durante 28 anos a sua vida
justamente pela supressão da sua
intensidade desde tenra infância ele
tinha desejo de troca de dinheiro com
suas amigas nos em troca de corpo mas
ele foi entendendo longo do tempo que
aquilo não era muito aceito para um
menino então para atender às
expectativas das outras pessoas ele
começou a cortar várias coisas que eram
extremamente importantes para ele
exemplo ele deixou de ser desenhos que
tinha meninas como protagonistas ele
parou de gostar as músicas da Eliana
Sandy e Junior Chiquititas Xuxa ele
aprendeu a xingar aprendeu a falar
gírias aprender a sentar de perna aberta
e ainda desaprendeu a fazer essa letra
cursiva para fazer uma letra de forma
simplesmente feminino não pode ter letra
bonita ele acabava sempre coreografando
e pensando direitinho em cada movimento
que iria fazer justamente para andar
nenhuma e ao longo do tempo em sua
infância adolescência ele acabou sem
tomando com os meninos e ainda
continuava sempre fazendo de tudo para
que ninguém percebesse nada e para vocês
um menino normal
final das contas o Thiago ele construiu
uma máscara muito forte de uma maneira
muito obstinado só que ironicamente essa
máscara realmente funcionou para todo
mundo que nunca suspeitou de nada
podemos dizer até que ele merecia uma Só
que essa máscara não funcionou para ele
mesmo
e já na vida adulta o Thiago ele nem
contrabalho como uma das grandes formas
de obter o reconhecimento da sociedade
só que depois de muito tempo de trabalho
intenso tudo que eu construídos ter uma
base muito sólida acaba que se tornou um
grande castelo de areia no futuro então
depois de muito trabalho intenso e muita
dedicação ele acabou sendo demitido
essa queda foi muito impactante para ele
mas também foi muito importante para que
Ele pudesse entrar em contato e consigo
mesmo e refletir sobre todas as decisões
que vinha tomando ao longo da vida além
de compilar todas as conversas que ele
teve com seu psicólogo últimos oito anos
essas conversas para lá vão sim e tocava
um sino tema LGBT mas muito progresso
não foi feito justamente porque os
maiores objetivos do Tiago era negar
todos os seus desejos e Se Curar dos
seus confusos desejos e troca de gênero
e
acabou que a vida levou ele para São
Paulo depois desse demissão que uma
cidade longe da cidade natal que aqui em
Belo Horizonte Além disso ele sempre
gostava de investimentos e guardava uma
boa parte do seu salário que permitiu
que ele construísse uma boa reserva
financeira E aí ele não precisava de
trabalhar para alguns anos
todo esse contexto e situação fez com
que ele tivesse paz para poder pensar
sobre o lá Pergunta muito simples mas
também muito profundo o que é que ele
faria se um dependesse de ninguém nesse
mundo para poder viver e É nesse ponto
que a história do Tiago se cruza com a
minha história a história da Natália
depois de tanto tempo Tiago realmente
assumir para ser que fazia assim parte
da comunidade LGBT que ia mais mas que
ainda tinha que vender qual leitinho ele
se encaixava não é que os seus desejos
não estavam completamente coerente com a
letra g dos gays e nem dedos bissexuais
pesquisando mais a fundo ele passou aí a
fazer estamos mais relacionados com sua
forma de se expressar e com sua
identidade de querer viver sua essência
e não com quem ele se sente atraído E aí
sim que ele entendeu que o campo da
transexualidade é diferente do campo da
homossexualidade e transexualidade é uma
conversa comigo mesmo Enquanto a
homossexualidade uma conversa minha com
outra pessoa
outra coisa super importante que ele
entendeu foi que pessoas eles vão
destruir o mundo não vão destruir a
sociedade harmonia que está entre a
gente cena LGBT não tem nada a ver com
falta de ética não tem a ver com falta
de caráter e não tem a ver com você
desrespeitoso com outras pessoas e esses
sim são os três pontos mais importantes
para que a sociedade possa definir o que
deve ser descartado ou mantido por nós
e foi depois de tantas reflexão e quebra
de paradigma que e eu nasci no final das
contas era como atravessar uma porta que
sempre estava lá mas que eu não queria
abrir de forma alguma não é verdade
várias coisas que antes eram motivo de
preocupação angústia e fuga uma coisa
que sempre fizeram parte de mim e só
aceitar isso foi o que me deixou mais
forte para ele tá com o mundo o olhar do
outro ainda continua lá mas eu sou mais
resiliente para lidar com ele e homem
para mim que eu ainda vivo sociedade eu
preciso seguir várias normas culturais
mas a diferença é que eu faço isso de
uma forma muito mais leve sem deixar que
o meu espaço seja brutalmente tomado e
hoje eu sinto que a relação que eu tenho
comigo mesmo é muito mais positiva e
estável do que elas ou que o Tiago tinha
com ele mesmo obviamente a minha
história minha jornada pela intensidade
tá obrigado compadre eu sei LGBT Mas eu
acredito que cada um nesse mundo tem sim
a sua barreira que dificulta viver uma
forma muito mais autêntica e saudável a
sua atenção e ela pode ter a ver com
essa forma de vestir com seu grupo
social que você convive com seu estilo
de vida não consigo no seu trabalho Cada
um tem sua história e cada um tem sua
própria jornada e justamente pelo fato
de ser uma coisa tão única para mim na
minha opinião que deixa uma coisa tão
maravilhosa e Libertadora E aí a gente
chega na parte da conversa que eu vi ele
falo é muito fácil né basta você pegar
um livro de autoajuda ver um vídeo do
Teddy contratar um Coach aprender a não
ter medo dos outros e ser feliz né
mas infelizmente as coisas não são assim
muitas vezes para que a gente possa
viver nossa própria alta intensidade nós
vamos ter que entrar em choque com a
cultura do Object e vamos ter que pagar
um preço por isso agora eu também acho
que é importante que a gente tem aqui
equilibrar as coisas equilibrar o que a
gente quer fazer com que o que os outros
esperam que a gente faça porque nós e a
ser sociais somos fomos sabe mesmo
sociedade e precisamos Respeitar o
espaço do outro no final das contas nós
vamos ter que realmente ponderar o
quanto estamos dispostos a pagar para
poder viver nossa essência mas eu Pela
Minha experiência eu acredito que as
recompensas são muito satisfatórios
principalmente a paz de espírito com
objetivo seu de vida outra coisa que eu
acredito é que essa paz ela só pode ser
encontrada dentro de nós mesmos e talvez
eu acho que essa foi a maior lição que
eu tive em toda a minha jornada quando
eu lembro do Thiago lembra que ele tinha
momentos felizes sim mas existe um
sentimento muito grande de incompletude
hoje como Natália eu aprendi a lidar com
as coisas que realmente Sempre fizeram
parte de mim e hoje eu me sinto uma
pessoa muito mais uma outra coisa que eu
acredito é que nós somos muito mais
complexos para ter apenas um muita coisa
para ter que preocupar lugar nossa
existência e é por isso que eu digo que
e ela é um processo para vida inteira
que requer muito alto conhecimento e
sabedoria para que a gente possa
realmente desfrutar da nossa essência
bom depois de tanto tempo todo reflexão
eu acabei também decidiram trocar de
carreira e atuar no setor que sempre me
deu muita satisfação que o setor de
economia e Finanças hoje eu atua como
especialista de investimentos para
pessoas físicas no Private Banking do
banco multinacional gerindo uma carteira
de quase 1 bilhão de reais e sabe que
que eu mais gostoso disso hoje eu sinto
que o trabalho serve a Natália e não
contrário
outra coisa muito legal que eu descobri
nessa jornada foi até a grata surpresa
de ter sido muito mais bem recebida do
que eu imaginava que seria de fato eu
comecei a entender que a grande maioria
das pessoas obviamente excluindo a
minoria não são pessoas preconceituosas
e uma forma imutável na verdade muitas
vezes elas são pessoas que têm o medo do
desconhecido e do Novo pensa só quando a
gente cria um padrão social gente cria
fronteiras do que a gente considera como
certo e o errado e dentro das Fronteiras
gente tá bem confortável só que nós
temos muito receio de que atravessar
esses limites de viver fora deles possa
trazer a insegurança e de estrutura
aquilo que foi criado no passado e esse
mesmo que for para pensar e super
legítimo por isso que pode demorar
vários anos para que realmente
preconceito no coração que alguém seja
eliminado Eu não falo isso tudo para que
a gente tem que esperar passivamente e
sentado para que as mudanças aconteçam
mas que a gente possa entender como
funciona a mente humana para isso em
atuar de maneira correta e trazer as
mudanças que são necessárias para nossa
sociedade e Quanto isso a gente celebra
o que for acontecendo no meio do caminho
vamos ter que ter paciência também
porque as mudanças costumam ser muito
lentas e graduais outra coisa muito sou
interessante eu ver que ser aberta com
uma história ajuda as pessoas a ter
contato com e frequente e entender quem
frequência não está relacionada
diretamente com a normalidade pessoas
LGBT pessoas trans são tão capazes e
competentes quanto qualquer pessoa não
LGBT
nós existimos desde sempre e somos tão
normais quanto vocês Infelizmente eu
gostaria que essa minha experiência e
sensação que eu tenho olho fosse a
sensação que a maioria das pessoas LGBT
e pessoas transferem por Aí Mas essa não
é realidade
imagina Muitas pessoas têm problemas com
a família tem problemas no emprego
problemas nos seus círculos sociais
imagine uma situação que uma pessoa é
expulsa de casa por ser LGBT outras que
sofrem bullying já quando criança que dá
vontade de sair do colégio que vai
impactar na sua busca de trabalho futuro
outras pessoas acabam Nem sendo
contratado simplesmente pela sua
aparência de fato a realidade é mais
dura para uma grande maioria das pessoas
eu não represento o cotidiano das
pessoas trans eu não sou a regra eu sou
exceção o relatório de violências contra
pessoas LGBT que ia mais publicado pela
Universidade Federal de Minas Gerais em
2020 apontou que 26,6 por cento das
pessoas entrevistadas durante o estudo
se sentem pouco ou nada colhidos no
mercado de trabalho mas a principal
demonstração da exclusão que pessoas
LGBT enfrenta no dia-a-dia é também a
falta de dados oficiais do governo o
maior exemplo disso foi a ausência de
perguntas sobre o gênero e sexualidade
no Censo demográfico 2000 e 21 do IBGE a
maior pesquisa demográfica na América
Latina sem dados oficiais sobre os
problemas enfrentados por essa população
fica ainda mais difícil e propor
soluções e políticas para melhoria da
qualidade de vida dessas pessoas então
eu faço uma pergunta para reflexão que
vale a todos Como podemos alcançar Nossa
autenticidade quando a cultura externa
não nos aceita ou não aceita nossos
comportamentos e para mim sem Três
Passos primeiro deles é verificar se
você está fazendo com outro aquilo que
você gostaria que estivesse fazendo com
você respeita outro é uma coisa
fundamental o segundo passo é ter um
grupo de apoio um ciclo de acolhimento
de pessoas que vão te ajudar a ter uma
estrutura emocional durante a vida
enquanto o debate da mudança está
acontecendo na sociedade e o terceiro
passo é participar de todos os processos
de alguma forma da forma que você
conseguir a gente tem sempre que lembrar
que em uma democracia nós temos todos
liberdade para poder colocar vários
assuntos em Pauta discussão na sociedade
as questões LGBT e transexuais São Sim
claro exemplo de um tema que precisa de
debate da sociedade
caso A grande maioria se e aqui a
mudança proposta não vai destruir o
tecido social que nos mantém em harmonia
essa mudança e novo paradigma vai ser
inserido na sociedade ao longo do tempo
de fato a gente tem vários exemplos de
como a sociedade foi evoluindo ao longo
do tempo Pense por exemplo na abolição
da escravidão ou nenhuma situação das
mulheres na sociedade muito ainda
precisa ser feito mas não podemos negar
que já andamos bastante nesses últimos
séculos lembro de quando eu falei que
parei de tocar violino porque as outras
pessoas disseram que aquilo era uma
bobagem bom Falou comentar que o Real
motivo de ter parado foi que me disseram
que aquilo era uma coisa de menina
e naquele momento eu tava realmente
fugindo de quem eu era e todo mundo está
fugindo de quem realmente é quando não
busca sua própria autenticidade eu
demorei 28 anos para encontrar esse
caminho mas tem pessoas que demora uma
vida inteira e outras ainda que nem não
consegue três experiência ao longo da
vida e de fato para mim isso não deve
ser visto como uma corrida para ver quem
chega primeiro e sim que devemos fazer
até coragem para estar nesse caminho
cada pessoa nesse mundo independente que
seja preta branca rica pobre e LGBT ou
não etc precisa estar em contato com sua
autenticidade se quiser viver de uma
forma mais leve nesse mundo que já é tão
caótico E isso se torna ainda mais
necessário se você faz parte de alguma
comunidade que vive à margem do padrão e
eu levo comigo a seguinte oração que me
ajuda sempre a lembrar que não sabemos
tudo e que sempre precisamos rever
nossos paradigmas para que a gente possa
construir uma sociedade cada vez mais a
ser sempre evoluindo no futuro e orações
seguintes senhor dai-me força para mudar
aquilo que pode ser mudado dai-me
resignação para aceitar aquilo que não
pode ser mudado e Dame sabedoria para
distinguir uma coisa da outra
e eu nasci de novo e essa foi a melhor
decisão que também na minha vida que me
conheceram passado sabe eu continuo
sendo a mesma pessoa só que muito mais
descontraída e confiante isso tudo era
justamente o que buscava com aquela
máscara que eu tinha criado Eu só não
sabia que jogar lá fora seria uma
solução obrigado
E aí